President Donald Trump has been impeached
again, making him the only president in history
to be impeached two times.
And in fact, this has been a presidency rife
with firsts, but they're all pretty bad.
And we're going to talk about that in a subsequent
segment.
But, yes, Donald Trump becoming the first
president to be impeached twice the House
this time voting on just a single charge,
citing Trump's role in inciting that mob that
violently went to the Capitol on January 6th.
And Donald Trump now will face a Senate trial
that could disqualify him from future office,
although that Senate trial by every indication
isn't going to happen until Joe Biden assumes
the presidency, 10 Republicans joined Democrats
in the House of Representatives in voting
yesterday for the impeachment of Donald Trump.
This was now a capital much more militarized,
much more fortified by law enforcement and
military as a result of what took place on
January 6th.
Let's go to the moment that it happened.
Nancy Pelosi announcing the results for the
second time during Donald Trump's presidency
that indeed the president has been impeached.
On this vote, the yeas are 232, the nays are
197.
The resolution is adopted without objection,
the motion to reconsider is laid upon the
table.
OK, so going forward, when we say the Trump
impeachment, we are going to need to clarify
which of the two Trump impeachments we are
referring to and notably different this time
versus the House vote about a year ago, a
little more than a year ago in impeaching
Donald Trump, the first time, 10 Republicans
joining the Democrats, Congressman CatCo,
Liz Cheney, Kinzinger Upton, Herrera Butler,
new House Mayor Gonzalez, Rice and Valadao
joining the Democratic Party.
I don't think that these Republicans are particularly
valiant or brave, although we will talk on
the bonus show today about how Liz Cheney
is facing calls to resign because she voted
for the impeachment of Donald Trump.
Can you imagine resign because you did the
thing that is your responsibility and duty
to do as a member of the House of Representatives?
Very backwards, very backwards calls for resignation.
We are hearing from Republicans.
And this is going to be yet another stain
on Donald Trump's legacy only one week before
leaving office to the day.
And we are I mean, listen, this this we talk
we've talked a lot over the last four years.
As we've fallen further and further down in
terms of global respectability, and as the
shame has grown and the humiliation has grown,
we've talked about what will it take to get
back to where we were.
And for many of us, where we were wasn't that
great.
I mean, OK, diplomatically, the United States
was more respected around the world under
Barack Obama and previous presidencies, but
we still were falling behind in dealing with
climate.
We still weren't getting health care to everybody.
Even as one of the richest countries in the
world.
We still had hunger.
We still had unemployment.
We were far better off than we are now, far
more respected.
But we still had serious problems to solve
and we cannot.
It is unreasonable to expect that after this
level of global shame and domestic shame,
just because the Trump is don't feel ashamed
doesn't mean it's not significant shame.
It took four years for this to culminate in
Donald Trump's second impeachment and this
riotous mob that he incited.
It's going to take more than six months to
make significant headway in getting out of
it.
And hopefully our historical allies will will
forgive us.
That's really the question.
And there is going to be a lot of work digging
out from this.
Even many Republicans in House speeches yesterday
in the anticipation of this vote, including
Representative Kevin McCarthy, conceding that,
yes, Donald Trump was to blame for what happened
at the Capitol last week.
But many continuing to insist that despite
that, it is not impeachable.
So we are all, of course, disappointed that
there are unlikely to be greater consequences
for Donald Trump if things go incredibly well
and the Senate votes to convict when they
likely in February, March, April, we don't
know, convene for the impeachment trial of
Trump if they were to convict.
It is a possibility that Trump will face the
consequence of not being able to run again.
But we all wish there had been more consequences.
And I think maybe the biggest takeaway is,
were it not for you getting out and voting
in 2018 to take that majority away in the
House of Representatives from Republicans,
were it not for you voting in 2020 to remove
Donald Trump and to give Democrats a Senate
majority, we wouldn't even be seeing a lot
of what we've seen.
The first impeachment wouldn't have happened
were it not for the twenty eighteen vote,
the second impeachment.
I mean, we'd be dealing with a different situation,
let's put it that way, were it not for taking
the White House and the Senate in in November
and in the runoff elections in Georgia in
January.
So there are successes here, but we all wish
that there had been more consequences and
earlier on for what has been arguably the
most atrocious presidency in modern political
history